so what I want to do today is talk as
Michael said about work that I've been
doing for the last decade or so on
personalizing the search experience and
I want to do that by highlighting both
the tremendous opportunities and I think
the need to do so but also to talk about
some of the the challenges that that
happened when you think about
personalization so I want to start by
providing an overview of perspectives on
personalization by thinking about how
Michael Michael alluded to this search
happens not in isolation but in a
broader context and so I'll talk some
about that I'll talk about a framework
that we developed to understand the
potential for improving systems by
personalizing them and then I'll give as
many examples as we have time for and
I'll spend the last 10 minutes or so
thinking about challenges and and new
directions so let's start with the
perspectives so oh actually before I do
that what I want to do is really
highlight why I'm excited about this
this area and why it's increasingly
important so about 20 years ago the
first graphical browsers were introduced
these were early web search engines so
Infoseek Lycos you notice that google is
not there yet here's the online presence
that some institutions had so this is
Stanford's computer science home page
updated 8th of May 1997 by WPB whoever
that might be
you don't see that on modern search
engines not New Times Roman font here's
the human-computer interaction seminar
that I guess I'm giving today one of the
interesting things if you have really
good eyes is that James Landay from
Berkeley spoke February 12th 1999 so i'm
following you by 21 years i guess that
the page actually hasn't changed that
much this bar has moved to the top and
the goofy 3 dimension but there are
other pages on the web have changed a
lot more this was Microsoft's researches
homepage in 1997 it too was New Times
Roman it had a search button and some
really interesting nav features the size
of the web around this time was about
3,000 sites
the size of Lycos one of the earliest
web search engines when it debuted was
54,000 pages that number of search
engines that that number of sites is
probably added every minute or so these
days furthermore they index only the
first 128 k of a document because they
were worried about copyright of web
content it also had this super
interesting link that I remember using
called the top 5% of sites in the world
so you could look at what the top 5%
were imagine doing that now the other
interesting thing is that there was very
very limited user interaction data so
there were about 1,500 queries a day and
that's partly because a lot of search at
that point happened on the client things
like a search for help in in office or
in other systems was all client-side and
the revolution of increasing the size of
the web increasing the number of pages
indexed by web search engines and most
importantly by having this feedback loop
of what it is that people do have have
changed just tremendously so today we
have billions of websites trillions of
web pages are indexed by modern search
engines there are trillions of web
searches and clicks per day perhaps that
the most important thing I think is that
search has gone grown from being kind of
an esoteric skill that you needed two
years in graduate library school or
maybe a master's degree in computer
science to master to something that
absolutely everybody uses every day and
they use it how many people are searched
today on the web how many of you have
spent your lifetime with web search
engines there are some people at the
back who have never lived without a web
search engine certainly my grandchildren
don't know what it's like to go to a
library to look things up they expect
this information to be there 24/7 it's
used for everything from finding
information to planning travel for
things like important things like health
information troubleshooting and so on so
it's gotten from being something that
was very very esoteric to something that
people depend on every day for more and
more information it's all so pervasive
I'm going to talk today about web search
and so I've done a lot of work in that
area but you search everywhere it's on
the desktop it's within apps it's an
enterprise and and so on and I think one
of the things if I have time at the end
that would be fun to talk about is how
more and more I think we need to provide
people access not just to search on the
web but to the many ways in which in
places where we interact with
information and I think because of the
pervasiveness of search systems it's
more important now than ever to think
and about how people interact with
systems what they want to do that they
can't do and to support them in doing
that and I think personalization is a
key part of that that story so when you
think about web search you often think
about a query 2.3 words on average
something happens in the black box and
then results magically appear right
that's how an information retrieval
person often thinks about search and
they worry a lot about what's in that
black box what I want to talk about
today is the fact that search doesn't
occur in isolation these queries don't
drop from the sky into a search box
they're issued by real live human beings
with an information need that the
documents the content on the web is not
unrelated it's related very richly by
what site it appears on by cross links
by Co interaction patterns that that
people have in navigating the web and
you know perhaps most importantly is by
and large people don't search to have
fun they don't search for kicks right
like I I love search I've been doing it
for almost 40 years now and I don't get
up in the morning and say hey I think
I'll search for kicks I do it because
I'm looking for information because I
want to satisfy some need it could be a
vague one like I want to catch up on the
news but I don't do it just to to have
fun and the more we understand where the
search queries are coming from what the
rich and interrelated structure of web
pages
and most importantly what tasks people
have the better job we can do in
satisfying people's information days and
so what I want to talk about is the fact
today that if as a web search provider
you have a single ranking for every
person at every point in time you're
going to do that fundamental
fundamentally limits the quality of that
search experience okay and the what I
will describe in a minute is how we can
quantify the variability that different
people have when they issue the same
query so how many people looked up news
today okay what site did you go to a
person with the New York Yankees jacket
what did you look okay one there's a
person over there what did you look at
okay we'll do one more you're smiling so
people had the same information need at
some level to find out about and you
went to very different sites so it
allows a web search engine to respond to
that and what I'm going to do is try to
quantify how different people have
different intents and how you can
discover those and I'll do that through
this this technique called the potential
for personalization so on the x-axis
here imagine you have a number of
different users in this case it goes up
to only six and on the y-axis you have
some measure of the quality of the
search experience in this case it's n
DCG normalized discounted cumulative
gain and what that means is you
basically measure the performance of a
system by high how high up in the rank
it gets the right information okay so if
I personalize if the systems were
personalized to you as individuals we'd
have a hundred percent score the more I
add multiple people whose information
needs I need to satisfy at the same time
we saw three people here looking for
news and they had three different sites
to go to the more that a single ranking
is when a decrease in performance and
this gap is what I call the potential
for personalization you can close this
pretty big gap by not improving the core
ranking algorithm necessarily but buying
try to understand a little bit about the
context in which that query is being
asked there are different ways to
measure what individuals want you can do
like I did ask people that's an explicit
judgment you can measure it by what
people do so if you issue a query and
click on the same site over and over and
over again any search engine that
doesn't learn that is is stupid you can
do it through content analysis there are
a variety of ways of doing it and that
we did some studies where we did
explicit judgments for a large number of
queries and what we found is that you
can get 46% improvement so this is that
the ranking will say of modern web
search engines this is what you get if
you personalize if you individualize
there's a 46% improvement that you can
get here and there's another 24% if all
you do is personalize with whatever
current ranking system is so there are
fundamental limits as to how high this
can go it's never going to go beyond the
variability and what people mean for
different people mean for the same query
okay so not all types all queries have a
high potential for personalization New
York Times if people type in the query
New York Times 98% of the time they go
to one page and why time's calm on the
other hand a query like chi can mean Chi
Chi Rodriguez it can mean the computer
human interaction conference it can mean
Taichi it can mean lots of things and so
here's actually a fun query where you
look at maps the first one is Bing Maps
almost everybody goes to the same site
if they issue that query Google Maps
similarly if you get to Texas County
Maps there's more variability and what
people click on if you go to street maps
is even more variability so different
queries vary in the amount that you can
improve them by through personalization
and so in a lot of this work we learn
models about how
personalized so let me this is a I gave
part of this talk at Chris Manning's IR
course a year or so ago and so what's
the potential for personalization for
the queries stanford ir course hi
high-ish louis hello yeah also means
stanford program for international
relations chris's book it means also
stanford interventional radiology all of
whom offer courses there's a not it's
also a part of the catalog so there is
actually a fair amount of
personalization
going through a different site or also
within the site itself both of those i'm
to a different page so these are clearly
high-level different in intense but even
if we agree that it's stanford
information retrieval course chris
Manning's course there are lots of
things that people do they might want to
go to the course policies to the
schedule to a calendar to some piazza
does that still exist two other things
about one homework is do so given the
same intent i mean you can think of the
first kind of difference is extrinsic
diversity so the things that we are
different targets but even if you know
what the intent is at a high level there
are lots of different things that people
want to do within that that site and
then again we talked about how you can
identify the interest how would you
identify people's different interests
how would you identify people's
interests sure i was looking behind you
but will will go there next will go
there next
go forth will be based on the prior
things that they were doing or prior
things that they were saying we're
talking okay
location location these are all things
that will appear soon so there are lots
of things you could do right you could
look at past behaviors even in the
current session you could look at longer
history of interaction and and
preferences you could also look at
contextual metadata location time what
device you're on all of those things are
going to matter in terms of what's
relevant for a particular query and in
doing all of this we need to build a
model of a person and you can do that by
looking at a variety of sources of
evidence you can look at behavior you
can look at content of pages that they
visit you can look at context this
broader contextual metadata you can look
at this over a short period of time you
can integrate over just what's going on
in this our course you can look at much
longer term patterns of behavior and you
can end up talk about this as
personalization but it really might be
better talked about as contextualization
so it I mean it I can mean an individual
I can mean everybody in this class I can
mean everybody who attends Stanford
everybody who's in a particular location
at a particular time so it's a variety
of contexts it's useful to take into
account and then how do you use the
models and where do they reside so they
could reside on the client they can
reside on a server they could be used
for ranking they could be used to
suggest queries they could be used for
presentation and then the question is
when do you use it do you use it for
every search query some of them do you
learn when to use it and what I'm going
to do today so these are all choices
that you need to make in delivering a
service that's personalized and I'm
going to give you four examples that
kind of span the space of the very very
rich design space that that's shown here
so one is a very simple system that
Michael mentioned earlier did both at at
Yahoo when she was an intern and at
Microsoft called
personal navigation and that system
takes us a model of a person's interests
only their previous queries and the
pages they clicked it's a pretty simple
model its long-term it looks at people
over a year or more it's done at the
individual level the model in this case
resided on the server and it was used to
sometimes influence ranking okay I also
worked on a system called personalized
search which had a much richer model of
a person's interest it was everything
that was on their desktop machine at the
time now you might think of it as every
page you've encountered in a browser or
an app so a tremendously broad
perspective long term again individual
here the model resided on the client
alright so and it was used both for
ranking and presentation and we used
that either all times or always or
sometimes and then in the last example
I'm going to talk about we built a
system that used both short and long
term context a pretty wide variety of
things mostly web content and it was
done both at the individual and group
level so this is a much broader notion
of representation of my interest both in
terms of the current acute needs as well
as longer-term preferences and it was
used in ranking and we learned when to
use it ok so let me start on on these
I'll get through as many of these as I
have time for and so let me start with
the personal navigation so when we think
of web search you think about people
discovering new information but in fact
a lot of what people do on the web is to
go back to sites they've seen before
so did you have you looked on the web
today yes what was the last the lat the
last site you went to had you been there
before or was it a new site okay you've
been there yesterday
okay Michael what was the last site you
looked at and had you looked at it
before your bio
somebody else and has you looked at a
Spanish dictionary before you must be
taking ask at a Spanish class okay so a
lot of the things that people look for
you've looked forward before a lot of
the things you've clicked on you clicked
on before a large proportion of these
are things in the square that says
repeated queries and repeated clicks
these are essentially navigational
queries where you take a query like New
York Times and you always go to the same
site these are consistent intents across
individuals and you can identify these
these kinds of navigational intents so
people go a lot not just to understand
or find new information but to get to
places this notion of navigation which
was completely unexpected when people
built the first search engines they
expected two people to do library
searches and they're using search a lot
to get someplace rather than two to find
information
these can be these kinds of navigational
queries can be identified in lots of
ways
they have a pretty consistent click
behavior and they also have anchor text
to folks might know what anchor text is
it's links that point into a page there
is very little variability in how people
address what they're pointing to for
navigational queries so for New York
Times that might be New York Times or NY
Times much less variability than then
what you see in webpage content there's
also a notion called personal navigation
queries so these are queries where you
might have different intents across
individuals but they're consistent
within an individual so for me Michael
talked about my work in KY but I also do
a lot of work in information retrieval
so if I type and I was chair of the Cir
ACM group so if I type in Cir I want to
go to dub dub dub CGIAR comm right and
in the Bing rankings at the time it was
not all that highly ranked this other
guy named Stuart Stuart Bowen jr. he was
the Special Inspector General for Iraq
reconstruction also abbreviated
and he would go to a very different page
but when either one of us asked the
query we probably went to a very
consistent site so this is an ocean
where the intent is varies across
individuals but within an individual
it's very consistent and so there were a
number of experiments done to first of
all identify the potential here and this
was done through large-scale log
analyses and what you can see is that
there's actually trivial algorithm like
ten lines of code that will tell you
when something looks like a personal
navigation query it's when a person
issues a query clicks on one and only
one result if they do that twice in a
row the chances that they do at a third
time or something like 97% okay so this
turns out and furthermore it covers a
large proportion of queries so 12% of
the queries on the web at the time we
looked at this were these kinds of
personal navigation queries and the
prediction accuracy overall was 95% and
so when in working with being in the
early days this was the kind of high
coverage and low-risk personalization
that they were willing to try early on
they were totally freaked out about
trying to personalize web search results
and then all that work was done to try
to identify the potential using
large-scale log analyses and then the
way that we evaluate anything in and I
think most people who run large-scale
web services do is through a B tests or
controlled experimental tests and those
confirm the the benefits of what we had
seen in the launch that doesn't always
happen but in this case it did okay any
questions on that I'm going to switch to
personalized search so this is I
mentioned earlier is a much richer model
of a person's interest it was based on
previous interaction history across a
variety of services and apps and it the
model resided on the client a query was
sent to a web service more than 10
results were returned and we did all the
rear Anki on the client okay so
something like this happens I type in
kite 2020
goes to Bing you get some results back
you then assess each of those results
relative to my own model of what I'm
interested in right see even that one's
good that one's good next one's not so
good and then Yuri rank the results
based on this client-side model okay so
pretty straightforward and simple this
has great privacy constraints I mean
privacy characteristics because the I
only send a standard web query but what
it lacks is something that I think you
mentioned earlier what are my friends do
how do other people who behave like me
in this car behave or in the same
context as I am and so it has limited
portability it doesn't work if I move to
a different machine and it doesn't take
advantage of the interactions of many
people who are related to me ok so how
did this work this is probably more
detailed than is relevant but a
personalized ranking consisted of two
components a weighted average of the
standard web ranking and then a
personalized search result personalized
score and that personalized score was
based both on the content we essentially
took the log odds of a word appearing in
my collection versus the web as a whole
and we had looked at previous
interaction with that particular URL or
a back off to a site level so in both of
these measure the deviation essentially
of me versus the rest of the world in
interacting with the search results we
did a bunch of offline experiments using
explicit judgments these are sort of
painful to get but we also did an in
situ evaluation where we deployed this
prototype to about over 220 people for
several months and what we did here was
we presented a kind of bifurcated list
so here were regular search results and
on the top were two to three
personalized results okay and we just
looked at how people interacted with
those what we found was that the
click-through rate was 28% higher for
personalized results and if you looked
at so you if you looked at the strength
of the evidence if you use only cases
where you had a fair amount of evidence
you get about 75 percent
higher click-through rate which is
really pretty good and so what we did is
learned a model for when to personalise
we personalized when we're really
confident and not for every query and so
you know a 75% increase in click-through
rate based on moving those results to
the top of the list was was really quite
impressive and you see a lot of this now
in web search systems ok I'm gonna
switch gears again I'm going to do two
slides on each of these five or six
different topics and then we can talk
more broadly about some of the
similarities and differences so this
work was done by looking not just at
long term histories of interaction but
what happens when you have acute
information needs what happens during
the course of a session and we looked
both at language models and and topic
models we also looked again at behavior
specific queries URL clicks it turns out
that about 60% of search just sessions
have multiple queries and so you have an
opportunity when a search extends over a
period of time not it looking not just
at my long-term preferences but what
I've done really right now that can give
you some insights about what it is I'm
doing
and so here's examples of how you can
use just a previous query so if I you
know we type in Cir given the previous
query was information retrieval or Iraq
reconstruction that gives you some
signal of how to interpret this
ambiguous query I showed you the other
example of the stanford ir course it can
either be CS 276 which Chris teaches in
this very room I think international
relations or interventional radiology
ego given it psychological contract
given Eldorado Gold Corporation it's its
stock ticker and gave given Dangerously
in Love what does that mean what's the
relationship between dangerously and
love and ego anybody know
they're beyonce songs okay okay but that
if you saw dangerously in love and then
ego is a search engine you probably
shouldn't return stock tickers or
psychological stuff did you have a
question okay and then what we did is we
built a personalized model that combined
both long-term persistent interests as
well as shorter term acute information
needs and we did this combination using
a variety of techniques where we look
just at historical data just a current
data or some aggregation of those two
and so here's what we found
if you use just session level data you
get about 25 percent improvement over
standard ranking with no personalization
if you use historic data only you get
about 45 percent and then if you combine
those you get a benefit that's 65 to 70
percent better than the standard
rankings given depending on how you
combine the two there is really
interesting things that happen within a
session so the first query in a session
can only use historical data right and
you see all the methods are very much
the same but by the and so there's no
green bar here there's no session level
data but by the third session in a query
you're actually better off by a little
bit here in using only session data if I
say you can you need to switch
throughout the course of a session from
using whatever you need to learn what
information to use when I said now
there's an interesting thing in this
model when you're when you do this even
this combination of when you're current
need is either similar to or different
than your long term interest so here's a
person it's a fictitious person and this
is a distribution of topics in their
model of interaction over a long period
of time sort of a sports junkie if you
see another session is that consistent
with that model or not that's a typical
session you might see another session
from this person that has dentists
root canal dental implant dental implant
recovery something has happened in their
life and there's an acute information
need which is different than their
long-standing interest and it turns out
that about 6% of search sessions are
atypical like this if you look at the
topical distribution of people's queries
the most common topics when you have an
acute information need that deviates
from what you do typically is medical
stuff and interesting the computer
troubleshooting there's a lot of things
that go wrong with our fancy
technologies these kinds of sessions
also tend to be more complex and have
poor quality search results to begin
with and so personalization can really
help here and you can think of these
atypical sessions as doing what you need
to do versus doing what you want to do
and again personalization is really
really helpful when when you can do this
ok so we and here's just the results of
this work if you look at session level
data only you do really well for a
typical sessions you sort of are ok for
typical sessions if you use historic
only data you're really good if it's
aligned with your your previous history
and not so well if it's not and if you
use a hybrid that tries to learn based
on the current query how to weight it
relative to these two models of your
interests you do much better so all
three of these examples have Illustrated
I think how you can build an
understanding of what people are
interested in sometimes very simple
things like exact memorization sometimes
much richer models but you need to take
into account a variety of changes over
time the consistency of sessions
relative to each other I want to pop to
something that I think you mentioned
about using metadata about where people
are went what they've been doing and
their relationship to to others so it
turns out that queries are not uniformly
distributed over time you can see two
sets of and a lot of models assume they
are you can see Dancing with the Stars
has a weekly periodicity tax extensions
is starting to ramp up now
and after April 15th it'll drop off a
you know a cliff and what we need to do
again and what's so like who cares right
if the results are the same regardless
of when the queries issued it doesn't
matter but it turns out that what's
relevant to a query depends on what it
is so if I type in the query US Open
what do I want to get well in 2020 it's
different than 2019 first of all if I
type in US Open 2020 do I want golf or
tennis it turns out that that varies a
lot by the month it is it's a pretty
good predictor of which of those you
want imagine I type in US 10 Tennis Open
2020 very clear but here again it
matters if you're just before the event
what people want is the schedule the
time of the events they want to buy
tickets during the event what people
want is real-time scores where to see
them a live broadcast after the event
they might want general sights and recap
so this is a case where the intent is
really clear but where you are relative
to an event matters and so again search
engines need to deal with all of these
dynamics of both the content that's
available the queries that people issue
and most what's most challenging is that
what's relevant changes over time ok so
we we built a variety of change aware
retrieval models I'm not going to say
very much about these except to say that
we consider two factors in building
retrieval models that have a notion of
temporal dependency in what's relevant
one of them actually looks at changes
and words that occur on a page over time
because that can give you an issue of
what's particularly relevant some pages
are always some words are always on a
page so think about a the Stanford
homepage some words are always there
it's Stanford University it's located in
the same place others change over time
what news feature they may have on the
item and the longevity of a word in a
page can give you very good estimates of
what's
relevant at any point in time and then
we also look at these kinds of dynamic
user interaction patterns and if you use
these two sources of information you can
develop much better ranking models than
again if you treat things as uniformly
distributed and independent okay I want
to talk a little bit not just about
temporal context but spatial context
where you're located can help interpret
a word the word football or jumper or
Chips mean very different things in the
u.s. in the UK library or zoo or current
time can be given at many different
levels of resolution at a city level a
state level and then there are things
like Starbucks or pizza that are in a
micro level if I type in Starbucks now I
don't really want to know about the
corporation I don't want to know about
things that are close to where I live in
Boston I want to know about stuff that's
relative to me now and so they're really
interesting signals about your current
location that can provide really can
provide insights about what you're
likely to be looking at and so for all
this work what we did is looked at
queries URLs and inferred locations and
what we want to do is estimate a
function that looks at the interest that
I might have in a particular URL based
on my current location and similarly
what the query might mean based on my
location and there's clearly a
background model that doesn't take
location to account at all and so here's
a picture of this interest model this in
this case the query is SM H here that
clicked URL is s MH comm which is the
Sarasota Memorial Hospital and people
who are in Florida and maybe a little
bit on the East Coast given that query
click on this result there's another
group of people who click on s MH comm a
you they're much more broadly
distributed this is the Sydney Morning
Herald and these are probably expats who
live in the big population centers so
you can tell actually in this case
based on where the queries are coming
from what the likely intent is and not
all queries not all topics have a
location specific pattern like this the
ones that are most the cases that have
many of the most location centric URLs
are things like classified ads
newspapers local TV radio things that
are reasonably specific to a locale and
so again by modeling this notion of the
spatial distribution of what it is that
people click on given the same query and
this is done by combining a variety of
gaussians that that depend on the
resolution at which you want a moderate
model location you can do a much better
job of satisfying people's needs ok so
this just talks about the details of the
the ranking it turns out that the most
important features in improving search
for given location information is the
original ranking not surprisingly the
probability that the URL is clicked on
by others in this location and the
divergence of the KL divergence of the
model the location model for the
particular URL versus a global model and
here's here's just an example again of
RTA bus schedule and you can see that
there are pockets there's a pocket here
it refers to Riverside California
there's a pocket here around Ohio and
it's really just a Cleveland Ohio rapid
what's it called the Rapid Transit
Authority or something the Regional
Transit Authority and there's another
one another regional Trent Transfer
Transit Authority down in New Orleans
and so given this same query you can
have very different Geographic pointers
to what might be the relevant URL okay I
am gonna guess this is the last example
let me try to go
this so what are the challenges in doing
personalization is that you need to get
input from individuals about what's
relevant to them you can do it
explicitly it's a real pain how many of
you have done these inline surveys and
webs in any kind of system it disrupts
your flow it's it's tedious people just
want to dismiss the the item you can
look at explicit implicit data
interaction data but that is noisy it's
plentiful but very noisy what we wanted
to do this was to see if we could get
crowd workers to give us personalized
judgments and so we tried two different
ways of doing this one is what we call
dropping so I'm gonna give you some
summary of a person and I want you to
understand what that person might want
in the other case I'm not going to tell
you anything about this particular
person but what I will do is match your
behavioral interactions with these
people so here's an example yeah okay we
did several studies ok so here's I'm
gonna ask you to graph this person I'll
give you what do you think the rating is
1 or 4 what how would the person like
that lovely little salt shaker pair on
the right how many people say 1 1 or 2 3
or 4 alright so in just like 30 seconds
I you have a pretty good understanding
of what this person wants albeit in a
very simple part of their life
the other thing you can do is just look
at people who've rated these or
interacted with these and find the
people who are most like me and use
their predictions this is standard
collaborative filtering okay and so we
tried this we had people try to predict
others preferences for salt shakers and
food and a couple of different cities
grokking showing you an example of what
the person's behavior is to date works
very well for capturing simple
preferences people think the Turkish
love this task and it requires very few
workers and so you get all of
in either of these methods you get big
advantages over not doing any kind of
personalization matching requires many
more workers it's actually very easy to
do and the data is reusable so depending
on the nature of the tasks the
complexity of the preference spaces you
can use one or the other of these
methods to understand how you can
personalize what people want even if
even if you don't require long histories
of interaction from them or explicit
judgments and so I think crowdsourcing
is promising in domains where the lack
of prior data can limit performance of
more traditional methods there are also
you know big questions about privacy in
doing this ok so I want to spend the
last let me spend five or ten minutes on
this in talking about challenges or
opportunities and then I'll open it up
to two questions so there are a whole
host of challenges in in personalizing
systems I've alluded to some of them
some of them are very person centric
they have to do with privacy they have
to do with concern about serendipity and
filter bubbles they there are concerns
about transparency you type in the same
query twice in a row and you get
different results what the heck's going
on and then they're a bunch of system
level things so folks are interested in
system level challenges personalization
is a real problem I mean most web
services work by caching results if I
have a common query and different people
mean different things by it I can't
cache those results so all the caching
that you typically do is busted now
there are ways to get around that you
can cache a larger number of results and
do rear anka of a fixed set of results
but there are some some big system
issues and I'll mention evaluation again
yeah so privacy is is challenging the
fundamentally the query and the results
sorry the query in the model need to
live in the same place so it can that
model in in personalized search example
that I showed you it was private
everything lived on the client only the
query was sent to a server
that's fabulous in terms of privacy but
lacks in terms of the breadth of the the
broad utilization of those models it's
device-specific it's there's no
Community Learning it's actually quite
inefficient in a number of ways
there are cloud profiles and for example
web search any other modern web app and
the the challenge here is I think that
all service providers need to be
transparent about what they're saving
and provide control over what's saved
and and removing some of that
information and I think a lot of web
services are moving in that direction
there are other approaches like more and
more there are public or semi-public
models of an individual you can use
lightweight profiles for example only
queries that occur over the last K
minutes or within a current session and
then disappear after that you can match
to a group or a cohort that are similar
to me in a number of dimensions and so
we in practice explore not so much the
local stuff but you know how we can
provide transparency and control and a
variety of other approaches that are
lighter weight and might aggregate over
more and more people it's also an
interesting question about
personalization and serendipity you hear
this a lot it doesn't mean the end of
serendipity and we have some results
that suggest that it can actually
increase serendipity so we did an
experiment in which we looked at
relevance versus interestingness so for
any search result we asked people to say
is this relevant to your query or is it
interesting to your query do now
personalization not surprisingly finds
more relevant results that's what you'd
hope it also found more interesting
results and even when the results
weren't the interesting results were not
relevant and I think the reason for this
is when people talk about serendipity
they don't want random things they want
things that are related and grounded in
something about what they already learn
and do and push out in interesting
directions and so that's why
personalization helped I think in spite
of the fact that the results might have
been
that might not have been relevant they
were grounded in something about the
individual provided ways to expand in
ways that were not completely random and
so like the princes of Serendip in the
old fable you need to be ready for
serendipity and I think personalization
actually provides kind of guardrails
about not going too far off things that
are relevant and interesting and I want
to end by talking a little bit about
evaluation I mean in all of these
systems whenever you build a system
Michael and I were just talking about
this earlier you need to be able to
evaluate to know whether you're making
progress websearch in retrospect is
perhaps the easiest place to look at
success people stop everything they're
doing they issue a query they tell you
what they're looking for and by and
large they click something that's
relevant or satisfies that need within a
short period of time we were how do you
know if you're successful if you're
doing something what what was the
example that you gave Michael earlier it
was at Instagram how do you how do you
know if you're how do you know if that's
good it's a time spent is it repeat
visits how do you know if you're writing
you know a system like Word or
PowerPoint whether your changes have
made a difference do you want to measure
how long I spend how quickly I leave
which of those is relevant and so you
need to think hard about what's relevant
and how you measure those changes so I
in search again we have it kind of easy
you have two ways of measuring what's
relevant to an individual you can ask
external people to make judgments right
when you have external judges tell you
whether a URL is relevant to a query
that's fine it's a reasonable place to
start but it lacks the diversity of
intense that different people have it
lacks the realistic context you know s
mhm how are you going to judge whether
these sites are relevant unless you know
what that means and you know
crowdsourcing can help a little bit here
provide a broader diversity of
perspectives you can actually have the
actual person whose interest
then something be the judge you can do
that either through explicit judgments
or implicit behaviors what's nice about
this method is that it allows you to
explore a variety of alternatives in a
very safe way if you do it offline if
you do it online where you're actually
deploying the system in the wild you
need to be you know very careful about
what you deploy and so explicit
judgments here are very nice and that
they're really precisely contextual but
they're really annoying implicit
judgments are scalable they're natural
but again there's a lot of noise I click
on something and then I move back what
does that mean does that mean I was
interested it satisfied my needs
immediately they're whole set of I can
give a whole other talk on complementing
behavioral logs with other measures to
really understand what's behind people's
queries whether they're satisfied or
dismayed and really one way - one of the
things we spend a lot of time doing is
trying to bridge the gap between what
happens offline which you can get from
log data and what happens online when
you actually deploy a system because
there is a larger gap than one would
like if you look just retrospectively at
old data or at newer data so let me just
summarize and then I have but I think at
ten minutes or so for questions so I
think that the main thing I was trying
to get across today is that queries are
really difficult even something as
simple as a search query is really
difficult to understand in isolation
augmenting that query with information
about who's asking when it is where they
are what other things they've interacted
with what tasks they might be doing
provides a much better search results I
mean we saw that it can improve search
quality up to 70 percent of the time
there's a large potential for improving
search and personalization I've given
you different examples that look at
largely content both short term long
term look at spatio-temporal context and
a little bit at using crowd work to
provide some interesting insights
they're a bunch of challenges and I've
tried to highlight how we think about
some of those but I think the that main
takeaway from from this is that
personalization and contextualization is
increasingly important today in our
information rich environments it's
increasingly so in mobile and proactive
retrieval settings I think that we as
HCI researchers should lead the charge
toward improving the quality of
experiences but doing it in a way that
respects queues me respects privacy and
a variety of other things that that
matter so with that I'll stop I want to
thank a ton of collaborators and I have
five or six minutes now for questions so
thanks somebody's got their hand I can
talk to later I'm really interested in
how search researchers and engines are
thinking about the trustworthiness of
the result versus personalization if you
have somebody always supposed to fox
news and you show them a New York Times
headline and they're like oh Google has
a liberal bias I mean it feels like a
quagmire yeah there you've asked a
couple of questions in there so one is
trustworthiness and that's incredibly
hard I think whether it's web search or
email spam or a whole host of other
things frankly these are adversarial
situations there's money to be made by
moving your result or somebody else's
result to the top position and the
search industry spends a lot of time
trying to combat that I think you know
in terms of fate news people try but
it's an it's an arms race I think what
we can do is educate people a little bit
about the characteristics that some
trustworthy pages have and the
algorithms are really getting better it
you know
at understanding what makes for
trustworthy pages they can be all sorts
of things like the narrative in the
story so a lot of untrustworthy pages
don't have all the details that you'd
expect they come from you're from hosts
that come and go rapidly so there are a
number of signals you can use but it's
still a challenge the other one that you
asked is is really much more about
preferences and this is especially true
in most cases one of the things that web
search engines do do is try to diversify
the results that come to provide
different perspectives being actually
has something called perspectives and
you can see for certain queries both
pros and cons you can see information
from different sources and so I think
people are trying to provide some you
know diversification of the of the
search results but in studies that that
social media platforms have done there
really is a question of you can
diversify but if people continue to
select something that aligns with their
preferences or interests you know
there's not much you can do as a
provider you can remove those sites and
they'll just they'll go elsewhere so I
don't know if that interest it but there
were at least two different questions I
think didn't that yeah search engines at
some point I guess in the India like
focus on how they could be manipulated
and whether there was you know miserable
failure pointing to George Bush all
these data like in some ways are
occurring now in the space of social
media this information
and I wonder if you know your
experiences and search keep you
perspectives are advising what advice
would you give to the newer platforms
about what you've learned through these
processes ah yeah well I mean I can tell
you horror stories about you know spam
in web search right it first started out
with very simple things like people
would actually modify the page in ways
that were invisible to people so you
could add all these spammy keywords in
minuscule font or in the same color as
the background when that was detected
and put down then people started
spamming links right you'd have link
farms pop up it's lucrative enough that
your your link farm can disappear in a
month and people are making hundreds of
thousands of dollars a month so they'll
shut it down and move to the garage next
door there's behavioral spam companies
will spam each other's ads by clicking
through with BOTS and that's reasonably
easy to detect because it used to be
that a lot of the behavioral spam would
occur at 12:01 12:02 12:03 and so now
people have put on distributions that
mirror human response time and so
there's this ongoing effort to do it in
the case I think of you know some of the
social media sites people need to look
at a variety of signals that you have
it's not just the content it's where
it's coming from what the link structure
looks like how people are interacting
with it and it's you know it takes a
while to identify those features to
identify places that really stand out
and to try to mitigate it I don't think
there's a particularly quick answer
debates about how proactive the search
engine should be maybe more in the gray
areas that this person is clearly
spamming yeah there's you know there's a
spectrum there's there's stuff I think
that everybody would agree is a clear
spam there's others even just think
about it an email spam if I happen to go
to a website is it really spam that they
send me information if I forgot to
unclear
I want to unsubscribe I don't that's a
little gray and I think you see this in
a lot of these you know these things if
I rewrite the headline to make it more
click Beatty
that's spam and so there are cases I
think clearly are you see these attacks
where there's slight variations of the
same thing up hearing over and over and
over again from a single site and there
are others that are much greater and you
know as as providers of information
services you really need to worry about
perpetuating a single point of view
versus giving people a broader sense of
expression and I I don't I don't know
that there's a you know an easy answer
wherever there's a market you can buy
elections like this for 5k you can buy a
local election for 50k as president or
senatorial election wherever there's a
market there's going to be this
adversarial relationship there somebody
will win and loosen in this and you can
pay to be on either side with that what
what people find I think particularly
annoying is saying this is relevant or
not you might be willing and I think you
see it in some systems like Spotify
to say quick reading up not this one
right now and that's a very that's a
very interesting way of modifying your
profile you might you see it a lot in
systems that have faceted metadata so if
you have metadata about pages you can
provide easy guidance for somebody to
select like this but so you see some of
them I think with web search results you
don't see as much of it partly because
it's not entirely clear what metadata is
particularly relevant in shopping sites
it's very clear right it's size price
all sorts of other things okay I have
two seconds
- okay we're over so I'm happy this I'm
happy to stick around and answer other
questions